with ibm robotic process automation you
can build bots that work with us not
just for us your business needs to find
and capitalize on more opportunities to
improve accessibility and interactivity
with automation and that transformation
begins by improving not just what our
bots can do but how we interact with
them ibm robotic process automation lets
you build and expose native chat bots in
just a few commands automating
day-to-day tasks across your business on
a streamlined ai-powered interface in a
low-code easy access studio environment
your teams can use even if they aren't
developers
now your bots can help your team save
time and money while freeing up talented
workers to dedicate their skills to more
sophisticated activities it's time to
look inward and find a way to boost
performance across your enterprise think
of ibm rpa as your automation
accelerator you can write the script for
smarter customer experiences today
[Music]
you